नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि नेक्स्ट
एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम सीखने
वाले हैं जर्मन में पश्चिम ऑइल यानि
पॉसिबल
है तो यह पैसे वह इस क्या है पूरे वह जब
क्रिया इंपोर्टेंट होती है तो हम उसको
पैसे वसूलते हैं मतलब एग्जांपल दें तो मैं
जब क्रिकेट खेलता हूं तो मैं क्रिकेट
खेलता हूं इंपॉर्टेंट को एक्टिव पॉइंट
बोलते हैं और जब क्रिकेट खेला गया है
क्रिकेट खेला जाएगा जब हम बोलते हैं तो
इंपोर्टेंट क्या है कि क्रिकेट खेला जाएगा
तो इसलिए इसको पैसिव पॉइंट बोलते हैं जब
क्रिया इंपोर्टेंट है तो वह पैसिव वॉइस
होता है एग्जांपल मैं आपको देता हूं
पुरानी हिंदी मूवीस में होता था काम हो
जाएगा अभी काम हो जाएगा मतलब क्या कि
तुम्हारा काम हो जाएगा कौन करेगा तुमको
क्या करना है तुम तुम्हारे लिए इंपोर्टेंट
है कि तुम्हारा काम हो जाएगा राइट प्रिया
इंपोर्टेंट है तो इसको होते हैं ऐसे वहीं
अब यह बिल कैसे करना है यह अभी हम सीखने
वाले हैं ओके खिलाइए पैसिव वॉइस मेल करना
बहुत आसान है इट्स वेरी सिमिलर टो इंग्लिश
यहां पर थोड़े से बदलते हैं बटर अमेरिकन
से प्रेगनेंसी एक लेकिन तो इंग्लिश में
बना देते हैं तो आईपीएल क्रिकेट क्रिकेट
इस प्लेट तो आप क्या कर रहे हो बिट्टू का
आरोप लगा रहे हो और प्लेट कब पार्टिसिपल
लगा रहे हैं पासवर्ड एंटर करना है क्रिकेट
सिर्फ जर्मन में क्या होगा क्रिकेट
क्रिकेट तो यहां पर लगा अगर आपको फ्यूचर
टेंस के एपिसोड याद करूं कैसे चलता है वे
डू वीरवार इसीलिए क्रिकेट विंड स्पीड है
पार्टिसिपेंट्स वेयर प्रेजेंट परफेक्ट
टेंस पास्ट प्रेजेंट परफेक्ट टेंस समझ
सकते
कि क्रिकेट विंडशील्ड सिमिलरली पिज़्ज़ा
पिज़्ज़ा पिज़्ज़ा पिज़्ज़ा पिज़्ज़ा
ब्रेड गे इन थे तैल चित्रों के सिंपल इतना
बोलना कि मैंने आपको इस प्लेटफॉर्म बोलना
है तो उसके लिए बाय की जगह और इसलिए यहां
पर क्या होगा कि मीरवाइज सब्सक्राइब हमेशा
ही सिंपल अगर यह आपको समझ में आ पैसिव
वॉइस इन जनरल हम यह बहुत कम यूज करते हैं
जॉइंट करते हैं मोस्टली इसी रूप में यूज
करते हैं कि डिस्प्ले रूप में ऑफिस के और
चार से पांच रूप में आपको अभी देख बताऊंगा
पर वह और अपने याद भी नहीं रखें तो कोई
फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा बट जस्ट बिकॉज हमको यह
कंसेप्ट कंप्लीट करना है हम वह सीखेंगे तो
सेकंड मोड पर हम जाते हैं हमने अभी तक
क्रिकेट डिस्प्ले है वैसे ही होता है
क्रिकेट वॉइस प्लेट है क्रिकेट बॉयज प्लेट
तो इंग्लिश में ने क्या किया इसका वॉश
किया जर्मन में भी वैसे ही करना वेलवेट का
पार्ट होता है वह रिटर्न वुडन लें और
गोल्डन कैसे चलता है देखो एकदम सिंपल है
इस योर डीटेल्स एड्रेस मॉडल वीर वॉर्डन
पिछले क्या होता क्रिकेट वॉइस प्ले
क्रिकेट बोर्ड की स्पीड
कल क्रिकेट बुरडक गैस पीड़ित सिर्फ वर्णन
की जगह उड़न का आरोप लगाया सिंपलेस्ट अगर
आपको इससे भी ज्यादा अंदर घुसने कि
क्रिकेट फैंस पिंपले क्रिकेट हस बीन
क्लीयर्ड और परफेक्ट टेंस को तो इन एग तो
यह जैसे हमने इंग्लिश में क्या और नीचे
वैसे में क्या होता है उसका एक स्पेसिफिक
करने की बजाय जरूर प्लस
थे पार्टिसिपेंट्स व्हाय और एंड में
वॉर्डन वॉर्डन ओके तो क्या होगा क्रिकेट
अभी क्रिकेट ही असली क्रिकेट है तो
क्रिकेट इस गैस फील्ड वॉर्डन क्रिकेट इट्स
ग्रिप इन थे फ्रिकवेंसी के तो फिर
क्रिकेटर डिस्पले थे तो वहां पर क्या किया
था इसका ऐड किया है यहां पर इस करवर होगा
क्रिकेट वाह गैस फील्ड वॉर्डन लग रहा था
कि क्रिकेट प्ले करो
कि आगे इन जस्ट टू कंप्लीट द कंसेप्ट
व्हाट वे वांट टू डू इसकी ऐसे भी हम यूज
कर सकते हैं क्रिकेट कैंप लिए है
हैं क्रिकेट कैंप लेटरहेड तो जर्मन में
वैसे ही करोगे क्रिकेट कान कि उनका विशेष
रूप क्रिकेट का त्यौहार सिर्फ वेल्डन
प्लेसहोल्डर एंड लगता है क्रिकेट कांगेस
पीर व वैसे ही क्रिकेट क्रिकेट उस गैस
फील्ड इतना किया तो अभी कर लेते हैं
क्रिकेट क्रिकेट क्रिकेट क्रिकेट टेस्ट
क्रिकेट को सब्सक्राइब बटन है
कि हमने साढ़े प्रकार मैंने आपको दिखा
दिया बट र शुरू पहला पार्ट छोड़ कर बाकी
कुछ को लगने वाला नहीं फिर भी आपके
रेफ्रेंस के लिए अगर आपको यह टेबल दिख रहा
होगा मैंने यह सारे जो रूप है वह आपको दे
दिए हैं आप देख सकते हो पर इस सेंस क्या
है सबसे सिंपल सबसे सिंपल है फेस्टिव वॉइस
कब है जब क्रिया इंपोर्टेंट है सिंपली इस
द पावर करता आपको यूज करने की जरूरत नहीं
करना भी हैं तो फोन प्लस डू करके कर सकते
हो क्रिकेट विथ कौन है जिस फील्ड
इंपॉर्टेंट क्या है नॉर्मल कंडीशन में
वेलंकर वर्ड जो भी हो वह क्रिकेट विराट और
ऐड जो पार्टिसिपेंट्स व क्रिकेट विश्व कप
फाइनल ईयर के पीछे अगर आपको जैसे-जैसे
सेंटेंस में अंदर जाना है आप क्रिकेट
बोर्ड और टेस्ट क्रिकेट की लिस्ट की
स्प्रिट वॉर्डन क्रिकेट वार्ड स्पीड
वॉर्डन कर सकते हो और अगर आपको मंडल भर के
साथ यूज करना है तो क्रिकेट कांग
वृद्धि कर सकते हो अब बेसिक कंसेप्ट इसमें
सिंपल मुझे आशा है कि आप सबको पैसे वह समझ
में आया होगा हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड
में धन्यवाद